okay well everyone thank you so much for
tuning in for another casual talk today
I have with me Jacob Alfred
hello I think first of all thanks so
much for joining I was uh very of course
excited that you are into one piece
actually yeah I was just happy to talk
about it like I don't really have a lot
of platform to talk about it on my
channel so if anyone else brings me on
I'm ecstatic that's great to hear so in
case you don't know um Jacob has a huge
Channel where he does mostly think you
started mostly with the gaming and
Esports and then kind of branched out
into like sharing music stuff yeah a
little like psychology experiments
torture a little bit that's a little bit
of everything really that's super cool
so um obviously if you haven't heard
about him or haven't checked him out yet
link will be in the description below
make sure to check him out but for now
what are your thought let's Jump Right
In what are your thoughts on the latest
chapter
um you were like I remember you were we
were talking about it and it was like we
have we have to talk about this chapter
I have a lot of thoughts I'm like I'm
trying when uh you asked me to do this
and I was like setting everything up I
was just like
where do I start
like I I just don't know that I think
that's the hardest part
um I think the first thing yeah that I
want to bring up that not a lot of
people have it's just this big
revelation of like the the mythical zoen
I think that's a huge thing absolutely
and it's like
of course like all the viewers readers
Now understand that but I I do wonder
how long is it going to be in Universe
until Luffy figures it out it's probably
gonna be a while I feel like because he
he never might yeah yeah I think he will
probably at some point and yeah I think
there is a chance um I'm not sure what
your thoughts on this is because I feel
like for example kaido seems to have a
lot of you know Insight on who Joey Boy
is and so on and so forth yeah so I feel
like he might be one person who might be
like you're Joy boy
um and like just acknowledge that but
then it might also be someone like
Shanks actually when hopefully Luffy
meetings like in the next arcs or
something where he's I'm terrified
I think every chapter that passes Shanks
becomes a little more sinister
just in concept right
so is your take that you feel like
Shanks might turn out to be a villain at
the end or uh no like I don't I he's
just plotting like I know he's plotting
I don't know where but he's plotting I I
see as like I don't want to say like
Shanks is bad because it's like at the
same time when you look at like the four
you like the Emperors why would I just
see him like this one's good yeah like I
I don't know I have no idea what he he
just knows a lot and is terrifies me I
I just don't know how much longer wano
is but in the back of my head I'd still
love to see Shanks where do you stand on
that one
um you mean Shanks in wano or like just
moving on from wano and going towards
like Shanks and end of one or just post
wano yeah I think post one was probably
more realistic I see yeah maybe
um it's a good question I think like
we're definitely right now moving into
the climax of The like the big battle
there
so like that's gonna be probably another
like 10 to 20 chapters till that entire
battle wraps up
yeah we still need a kaido flashback I
think yeah that's what I'm waiting on
it's like as soon as we get that
flashback that's when I'm gonna like
accept that one I was ending yeah but
then like the question I for me
personally I'm curious like what's your
take on that is like they're I feel like
there's still potential to make that
like that the arc will be longer anyways
even if the battle is over because even
if kaido's defeated there's still the
chance that the Navy comes that
Blackbeard comes so that might be more
fighting yeah
um we have the zorros thing going on
there's still a lot of lore like with
the pony glyphs and so on and so forth
why it's important to open the borders
of wano so there's still a lot of like
stuff to explore that's kind of like
been introduced early on
yeah there's
there's just a lot because I mean you
also have Rob Lucci on the island as
well which is terrifying and then
um who knows where Blackbeard is who
knows where Shanks is uh one thing that
I I do think is interesting is that they
definitely like kind of teased
Blackbeard at the start of wano and he
is like not made an appearance yes but
he doesn't directly mean he's in wano
because I somebody showed me like uh I
think it's the the cover for 10.43 last
chapter and and it's just like German 66
and whole cake yeah yeah and are you
know what I'm talking about the cover
spread yeah yeah exactly yeah and how
they have the like the very distant
Invaders in the background yeah I really
like the theory that Blackbeard could be
like invading whole cake and it seems
like why would he Dodge the action but
he's kind of like an opportunistic
tactician because when everyone was
fighting in Marine Ford he goes to imple
down you know it just felt like the
exact same thing absolutely yeah I mean
both things would be interesting because
like obviously I think it would be
interesting if kaido was coming for you
know as Blackpool was kind of coming for
kaido's devil fruit as like the most
powerful Zone kind of or like one of the
most powerful Zone fruits but then again
that would also be interesting going to
whole cake Island you know like taking
over or getting the pony glyph and so on
and so forth the pony glove is like the
big one for me I personally would think
that there is at least someone in wano
who's gonna take it like kind of picking
on the winners I I really like the idea
that there's gonna be someone who's
going to be picking on like the straw
hats basically even though they won the
raid and so I think that would be a
great moment also for kaido who in my
opinion has been kind of built up to be
like a failed good guy
it seems like he was trying to be like
the hero of the world become the one who
changes the world and was kind of like
yeah folded like Harry Potter style for
the greater good like we're gonna have
to make sacrifices for this
kaido where he struck me as like the
little league dad who peaked in high
school and still has his letterman
jacket yeah that's actually
I like that
um all the antagonists are always
not happy you know like Rob Lucci
terrified crocodile tired you know like
everyone hates to see the little rubber
man stand back up but I love that kaido
just wants to fight you know Luffy
stands up and he apologizes and says
thank you I think that's so cool that
was a really cool like that apology was
like almost yeah like if they hadn't
been like the entire devil fruit thing
that would have been almost my favorite
part of the chapter I think I I do
Wonder like I think one it's one piece
is one of those things I'm sure you're
aware of like there's so many things
where I can't tell if I'm putting
together things that don't matter or
they're intentional and it's just it's
impossible to tell sometimes I do think
honestly to a certain degree it's
intentional that you don't know what you
have to put together yeah so I think
yeah that's that's kind of the fun thing
why even like the type of videos I make
for example for one piece or like a lot
of other creators make like he's more
like feel right like theorizing analysis
yeah it's not it's not so easy to do
that with other stories because Oda
other than other authors like is very
aware of like his community and how much
people yeah and he actively participates
in that he's just such a phenomenal like
artists at World building because I
think that's what it really is that's
what got me hooked on one piece because
I'm really good at binging media
consuming it and dropping it when I'm
done like never thinking about it again
yes and with one piece it's just like
I've thought about every chapter a
million times over just because I can
absolutely and it's it's also not only
is it like
writing a great story and building the
entire story overall but also you have
to balance the story as a big thing with
like the weekly audience that wants to
be entertained on a weekly basis right
so that's great um but yeah I I think
that's really cool and like did I see is
that like realtor 2 you have because I
just noticed that yes yeah yeah please
please show that that is so cool yeah
oh my God
I feel
like yeah I was just uh I mean I always
like use the like the tag like Ace on
like online forms and everything growing
up and then you know like I have my own
music project like Ace of Hearts yeah
yeah so I always even though like
honestly Ace doesn't really like do a
lot but I I just liked him as a
character just fine absolutely and like
I mean still like even though people
some people like to give him [ __ ] as a
character still he's had such an
influential role in like such an
influential role to play and so was one
of the most influential or like
interesting and important characters in
the story you know is Roger's son yeah
and I guess one could like my personal
theory is that Shanks originally was
looking for Ace because like Roger I
like that theory too right yeah and then
Luffy kind of was like oh let me let me
smack that
so yeah also the I think this chapter is
so cool because there have been like 30
different chapters in wano that rewrote
chapter one yes and this is definitely
one of them because it makes me it it
this chapter does make me think Shanks
is maybe not Sinister but just plotting
because scheming yeah yeah yeah
he it was never about Luffy it was about
the fruit yes
so like he protected Luffy for the fruit
but it's just it changes like the
connection between them absolutely I do
I would personally still suspect that
Shanks still cares about Luffy as a
person but I do think that like of
course I don't think like Shanks is like
whatever about Luffy but I also do think
that as you correctly say I think it's
more about the fruit and I think it's
more about like it doesn't matter if I
care about you as a person like this is
about something bigger kind of vibe yeah
yeah
I'm bringing it back to to the chapter
though what I'm yeah we've been all over
the place that's fine because
understandable like as you said this is
a chapter that not only rewrites chapter
one but also like the entire story as a
whole basically it sure does so do you
think for example for kaido do you think
fight fighting wise is it's like his
fruit you feel already awakened or is
that something will like does he still
have another Ace up his sleeve I think I
was thinking that exact same thing
earlier
um it feels like it should be awakened
because I I was
like uh Joy boy is like it kind of
looked like Luffy you know his voice
disappeared like he died and then like
the Awakening with the with the mythical
Zone had to hat like it you know like
death completes the cycle and everything
and it felt like to act like become Joy
boy he had to like
die essentially and then it kind of
makes sense why like kaido and like you
know the Beast Pirates like it's all
zoen users like I think he wanted Joy
boy he wanted to be Joy boy or create
Joy boy with like Yamato or something
like that so it feels like the Zone was
required
it and it sounds like kaido had like an
idea almost in the sense of you do need
a Zone
to awaken Joey Boy but it like clearly
he wasn't aware that it was a specific
one that he needed kind of or they were
trying to like find like one specific
fruit and like we're kind of like just
trying out what would happen which is
also again such a cool thing because at
the beginning like I'm not sure how you
saw saw that entire thing because you
had the chance to read it a lot faster
probably than most people who were like
doing it weekly
but when kaido was first introduced it
was kind of like a classic oh this is
like a big brood with like a big Club he
had like he likes animals and dinosaurs
and like that's all there is to it and
like now it's actually so much more
complex and like such a layered
character and even the Beast thing makes
so much more sense now which is awesome
yeah
yeah just everything because the one
thing I've seen people talk about is the
the obvious like potentially glaring
like plot hole of like why didn't the
world governments and people after Luffy
right yeah and I'm very much so in the
boat of like ow I'll figure it out I
don't think so as well I'm pretty yeah
I'm very not worried about that honestly
yeah people have one one new chapter
happens something changes and yeah I
think it's fine one thing that I thought
was really interesting to think about
someone brought it up in my comment
section recently
so shout out to that person was what if
Shanks actually
stopped kaido from going to the war not
because kaido wanted to like kill
Whitebeard or fight Whitebeard but
actually you know save him or team up
with him yeah yeah and he was like no no
we can't have you like destroy all the
Admirals and like take down the Marines
right now because that would not be good
yeah I I saw someone talk about like
what if that same thing and it was kaido
is so fixated on Joy boy and everything
and what if like he thought as well as
like what Shanks intended like what if
he thought Ace could have been Joy boy
and wanted to witness it like that one
is multiple stretches but it's still
interesting I think I think I'm not even
sure even because for example like again
going back to the idea that Chang's
knows what the government's true power
is and why like even someone like rocks
wasn't able to take them down and no one
in the last 900 years is like they must
have some sort of crazy power
yeah that's just like so destructive and
so I'm like maybe if kaido had teamed up
with Whitebeard and they'd taken out the
Marines maybe like emu and the gurose
they would have tomato like they would
have had to make use of like some crazy
power that would have been basically
like yeah it just it feels like every
way you look at it Shanks is playing
both sides yes absolutely and absolutely
that's I I think that's really what it
is all about it's like he he's playing
both sides and I don't know what that
means and which is it's just so
fantastic because it gives you exactly
that Game of Thrones the entry yeah
yeah which which I personally so like
that political maneuvering is just great
it's like little finger Vibes and in the
in the best way possible I feel like
this but there are several more spoilers
that could happen like and there are
several spoilers that have happened but
I feel like whenever shanks's intention
is revealed like that's one of those
spoilers where if you know at the start
it could change your perception on all
of One Piece absolutely and I do think I
personally am still very much convinced
that one piece is gonna be one of these
stories where when we actually get an
explanation for the how the entire world
came to be and how everything's like
where devil fruits come from and like
the lore of the story I think it's gonna
be like what the [ __ ] nothing is the
same kind of moment yeah yeah hopefully
yeah because I thought of think about
like when who's who dropped the C you
know the cp0 had the fruit and then
shank stole it and I don't know man I
actually have another question I want to
ask you because I'm actually working on
the video on that right now that I'm
going to publish either this week or
next week yeah depending on the next
chapter
um but one really interesting thought
that I think a couple of people have
including me and that I kind of want to
explore deeper is
I think it's very possible that
Blackbeard might not be a logia fruit as
well but you know it's a mythical Zone I
am 100 on that too
it's I'm not gonna go into my thoughts
but I do want to know what you think on
that I I think you know like one piece
story of Checker Fates
and all that and yes
um I like that theory so much I mean
it's just it's so interesting because
when you think of like antagonists in
one piece you think Blackbeard but he's
really like not done anything to Luffy
directly like they're just two pirates
on the sea like he turned an ace but
like that's like it yeah and they kind
of like fought a little bit uh like and
pulled down by that yeah they've met
once after knowing who each other were
yeah and that's it literally yeah and
I I feel like if Luffy does have a
mythical zone of like the sun god and
everything and Blackbeard has been so
heavily associated with like Moon motifs
and everything it's like I don't and
also the fruits look near identical
which is probably not a coincidence
either not a coincidence
sun and moon Darkness and Light yeah
yeah it's it's Blackbeard I don't you
know I don't know what moon God is or
anything like that but it's definitely
something that's the antithesis of of
Luffy's Nico Nico and I was just asking
on on the topic of of that right there
have you did you see the like the ace
and Blackbeard fight have you Revisited
that I have okay because I was like I
wanted to read that panel if you haven't
because that please please please yeah
yeah like you can you can still read it
because it's fantastic yeah I just had
had it like saved recently and it was
just when Ace was just like if your
powers are logia type and attack like
that shouldn't hurt yeah and it's just
like yes
feels a little different now and then
it's yeah oh I have yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna be quiet because I have a lot of
thoughts on this and I do want to turn
it into a video I do want to watch that
video though and if I can like say one
thing oh of course current chapter
um
what
what is Odin's daughter's name
Siri yeah
um what an incredible art for her that
gets completely overshadowed by
everything that happens with Luffy yes
yes yeah it's a beautiful Arc that would
have been the talking point if not for
gear fifth I that is actually the only
point of criticism I have criticism
right quote unquote it's like it's such
a great moment and it was put into this
chapter where like it should have been
clear that no one like it would sink and
like you know drop below the attention
of everyone under like what's going on
around it because I I 100 agree with you
she had like one of like a fantastic
character Arc in the entire story yeah
I'm happy you bring that up just taking
the mask off and seeing her crying was
such an incredible honestly just a
well-drawn panel first off and also once
again like very meta in a way because
you know like literally like dropping
your mask and like showing your true
feelings kind of in a you know very
visual way is like I love those kind of
seeds
absolutely yeah man it's been a pleasure
talking to you like let's definitely do
it again soon hopefully I hope I'm sure
there will be plenty of chapters to talk
about
um if you if you want to check out uh
Jacob's Channel please please do he has
you you basically you mostly do Nintendo
stuff but also like if any like
interesting game is out I feel like
you're mostly on it right yeah yeah now
I'm like kind of like soft pivoting like
I like doing a lot of like real life
stuff it's just it's just hard because
that just requires more work but it's a
lot of fun so I'm kind of like soft
pivoting back in between the two of them
that's great and well yeah and I I might
have a couple one piece videos planned
but who knows so even more reason to go
over to his channel and uh you know
watch his stuff so please do of course
Linked In the description below
um and yeah like you're I'm a big fan of
your music actually bro so thank you it
was a pleasure talking to you hopefully
yeah you'll be back on the channel soon
can't wait to talk again yeah it'd be a
pleasure thanks man